good morning everybody and welcome to
the next installment of the big data to
knowledge guide to the fundamentals of
data science this is Mark Pearson from
Stanford University and I had the
pleasure of introducing today's speaker
who is a professor Isaak kahani
from the Harvard Medical School dr.
Donnie has a distinguished career he's
currently the founding chair of the
department biomedical informatics at
Harvard and has a long history of
working in areas that ranged from the
molecular to the population level he is
probably best known most recently for
his work as the guy who led the
development of I to detune which is a
major resource which is now used over
120 academic health centers and around
the world as a way of managing both
clinical and molecular data we know that
in the world of big data we talk about
volume velocity and variety and clinical
data have all of that and it's a
pleasure introduce is act to get today's
talk so thank you very much my pleasure
to be here this my name is Isaac Ohana i
am called by most people zack and i'm
glad to talk to you today about
considerations for a clinical data for
precision medicine before I go further I
just want to just check with my
organizers that you can see my slide
that looks like the precision medicine
slide and that you can hear me it looks
good good thank you so this is a slide
just to remind you what precision
medicine was about at least what we
think it's about for those of us as I
was privileged to be who were members of
the National Academy of Science
Committee that helped write the
precision medicine report and in a
nutshell we declared that we had a
Google Maps MV that has show the left of
the screen we saw that by taking
latitude longitude and combining it with
a variety of other data types
namely for example whether pharmacies
traffic we would create a ecosystem they
created an ecosystem that now has
everybody engaged in applied geography
internationally and we said that if we
were to create a similar information
Commons that was centered around
patients that gave this multiaxial view
of patients not only in one study at a
time when from with God - let's say
environmental exposure or clinical signs
and symptoms or the microbial contents
of your gut but we brought all together
we would hope to create a similar
productive ecosystem by looking at each
patient from a much more well-rounded
perspective rather than the blocky kind
of categorical view that we have
currently in medicine and so some of the
points I will make in my comm today will
be that most population genetics and
clinical medicine is addicted to
categorical diagnosis and that addiction
creates some false or wrongly taxonomy
disease diseases and make social and
commercial construction of disease
likely sometimes for good sometimes for
ill it I also want to make the point
that clinical predictive accuracy does
not imply shared physiology and that
disease overlaps demonstrates a
fundamental problem which precision
medicine and its approaches are trying
to solve and that clinical data can be
used to lessen the confusion when a
brief show here a some ROC curves from a
paper published several years ago about
using a transcriptome of white blood
cells in patients with autism to
distinguish them from
the vigils who did not have autism and
the only reason I point this out is that
these fairly good-looking auc curves for
a brain disease at least as measured by
blood transcription caused me to be
invited to another school in my
neighborhood the Harvard Law School and
when I entered that meeting I saw an
individual who I was reminded that I
thought I had seen him on TV on network
TV in the past week or two and I
couldn't figure out who he was I just
couldn't remember and then it came back
to me when he asked me the following
question why are you trying to commit
genocide on my people and so this guy is
a new man who has a form of autism and
he takes the view that a lot of these
efforts for diagnosing autism amount to
trying to filter out these individuals
and eliminate them from our population
and therefore this constitutes a form of
genocide and I had a lot of discussion
but it really it made me think about the
diagnosis and but I would rather instead
of voicing my own comments voice
comments of a woman that who was public
about these on the web and she said I
think when Ari talks about autism and I
talk about autism we're talking about
people with different clusters of autism
I know he doesn't like the word cure if
my daughter would function the way Ari
could I would consider her cured set
singer I have to believe my daughter
doesn't want to be spending time peeling
skin off her arm so the point here I'm
making is this diagnostic label can
actually mean a lot of different things
to many different people and therefore
when we use them for example to do a
study of autism versus not autism the
nature of that label is going to
determine how successful we are
as during a study of heart failure
versus not heart failure would be very
different if we focused it merely on
heart failure due to atherosclerosis or
all the heart failures valvular efforts
chlorotic genetic sorry structural
protein defects or infectious which
would be lumped into what the
medievalists would call dropsy and so in
the precision medicine perspective i
think we have to become much more
careful about how we label these things
and perhaps less controversial but even
more vivid of the description of this is
dwarfism which is often caused by growth
hormone deficiency and although I have a
patient computer science I am trained in
pediatric endocrinology and this is a
group that endocrinologist have long
been concerned about because the social
and fiscal challenges of being quite
short can be considerable and therefore
it was a major big breakthrough when
endocrinologist discovered that they
could take the two trees from 60,000
cadavers and extract from these cadavers
from these pituitary's the protein
growth hormone and then inject them into
children with who were going to be much
less than 5 foot tall and lo and behold
group to above 5 foot tall the problem
was that because it was the it was
extracted from the 60,000 pituitary the
fact that there were a few individuals
with Jakob Creutzfeldt disease a slow
virus resulted in the deaths of several
children from this disease and you can
guess how those of us actually might
preview the previous generation before
me felt about treating having treated
these kids with the best of intent to
bring them to normal height feeling
response
for having caused their desk
unintentionally and that created first
of all a lot of happiness when we came
up with synthetic or bacterially derived
recombinant growth hormone that worked
extremely well and making these children
grow but because of this and I'll get
back to it shortly because of this the
plate place where I learned how to
practice pediatric endocrinology because
they had the memory personal memory of
this yak of quite svelte
I gave very low doses at both home
because they just felt that they needed
to be conservative now in the in the
mana genomic era work done by one of my
former order my former fellows in
pediatric endocrinology and now a team
colleague Joel hirschhorn ran this big
study called the giant study and what he
found was in the range of normal height
there is in the there are literally
hundreds of genes maybe 700 genes that
are quite informative of adult height
but each individual of eight individual
gene of those hundreds of genes various
variants that contributes only very very
minutely to toe height so your overall
height from perspective these genes is
only influenced a very very little
amount by each gene and so this is
unlike the diseases that the tails of
the distribution of height where
extremely short stature is the cause of
highly penetrant small numbers of
mutations sometimes a single mutation
which raises the question what do you
call short stature what do you call that
diagnosis when you have short stature
and you're not growth hormone deficient
what do you call it so it turns out for
a variety of reasons which I'll make a
parent
we call it idiopathic short stature now
why would you want to have a diagnosis
of a do Pathak short stature I think
just to label it to be a good doctor but
it turns out that's also useful because
it's a diagnosis that from civil
companies can use to drive the
prescription of growth hormone because
it may add one or two inches to height
and they had a very useful biomarker
called for the show here on the screen
which defines height with respect to a
standard deviation score and that
interesting of course because it means
no matter how high the US population
will be they'll always be people who are
below that threshold and therefore will
qualify which reminds me of a story
about 25 years ago when I was a fellow
in training I had published I was by a
submit an abstract about how with our
1/3 of a dose of growth hormone we were
achieving high velocities and adult
statures that looked just as good as
that of the general population those
treated with growth hormones those were
the growth hormone deficiency were being
treated with growth hormone and yet
we're only using 1/3 of the dose and to
make a long story short I got
threatening a phone call as a fellow
from the chief medical officer they're
essentially threatening me to block my
publications because she sat on the
editorial board of many endocrine
journals and this was a unforgettable
lesson to me that's tied to a diagnosis
and tied to these biomarkers around
diagnoses are huge amounts of dollars
and so being able to assign diagnosis is
always not always it's frequently going
to be a issue not just of science of
Finance
but also I want to remind you that not
only insurers or pharmaceutical
companies but even parents are to push
around the diagnosis so here's a case of
a father who comes in with a five foot
six child and still growing but he
because he wants his son to be a athlete
and perhaps a basketball player he is
willing to pay out of pocket the forty
five thousand dollars a year it cost to
give growth hormone and this raises a
bunch of questions a how does this cause
us to stretch our diagnostic criteria
and be is a parent wrong is this
actually a reasonable question and
something that we will have to face a
lot in the coming years next I want to
move on to in this context of
categorical diagnosis what's the
interaction between clinical annotations
and genetics and here or looking at
interesting interaction between genetics
and a categorical assessment of
ethnicity or race and a categorical
diagnosis and it's hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy for those of you who are
not clinicians is a disease that you've
actually heard of about because it
occurs it's been occurred it's been
reported in the newspapers when it's
famously caused unfortunately athletes
to die suddenly on a basketball court
and what it is is an inherited well not
a genetic disease sometimes inherited
that is also autosomal dominant you'll
need one copy of the gene and it can
lead to heart failure rhythms
obstructive blood flow and sudden
cardiac death but important is an
important fact to recall here is this is
1 in 500 and so my colleague and post
rajkumar I did a study where I looked at
the National Heart blood Blood
Institute's ESP study which used to be
thought of as big data but at 6,500
individuals even with exomes is not no
longer considers to be large big data
but if we had this disease at 1 in 500
that would give you about that much red
red as you see on that little cartoon of
those individuals whereas what Raj found
was a lot more red in the population
that is a lot more hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy than you'd expect for a 1
in 500 disease and when he then looked
into what was the ethnicity or continent
of origin of those patients in those
patients what he found was the following
an amazing over-representation amazing
over-representation of those individuals
who are african-american and why is that
well it turns out that individuals that
those who had run the study had in fact
done what they were supposed to do which
is have ethnically matched case in the
controls so it's probably the case that
all the controls were in fact Caucasian
and I think they sought to have
Caucasian or European ancestry cases but
it turns out that for example in one of
the studies in Paris they included some
individuals who were from Algeria or
from Algerian descent and similarly in
Boston some who has some relatives who
were not from Europe and so what this
means is that
if you include in the cases individuals
who are from Eva who are who have recent
lineage to Africa then you're going to
make it such that they're going to have
a lot of alleles that are just not
present in the Caucasian or European
American controls because most because
the Africa create born Africa where
those few families that thousands of
years ago emigrated from Africa to Asia
and Europe but just a few families and
therefore the representation of African
genetic diversity was extremely a sparse
and therefore when you do a case control
study and unbeknownst to you you have a
few individuals of African ancestry of
recent African ancestry in your cases
you will have this over representation
of these alleles which actually have
nothing to do with hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy and lest you think that
this is a just a interesting statistical
result shown here from a intact one of
the leading laboratories of hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy are all those individuals
who were actually mistakenly diagnosed
it was a result of this kind of mistake
we published this by the way in the New
England Journal of Medicine last summer
and so these african-american
individuals were not only diagnosed and
possibly treated but because it's
autosomal dominant family members were
also reached out to because of course if
it's also autosomal dominant a lot of
family members will carry a putative lis
causal variant and unlike this lab which
went back and notified all the
emily's I'm not sure it's hard to know
what how many of the commercial apps
have done likewise but know what's
happened here because of an imprecision
of a diagnosis is making look asserting
that the diagnosis is this unitary thing
and also asserting that this label of
ethnicity is unitary thing we're making
inferences which end up to be damaging
and it continues also with regard to the
genetic part of the reductionism so here
we look up in clinical trials.gov
which studies are being looked at in
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy and there's
this trial going under undergoing that
is open now and if you look here in
group 2 there is a group that is has no
clinical evidence of ventricular
hypertrophy but has a mutation so they
have a complete normal-looking heart and
you could be have young as ten years as
ten years old and you'll be receiving
this drug for years as from as a child
and you've no clinical evidence and
here's the kicker
of course if you don't develop disease
you're going to be considered a
therapeutic success where in fact as I
hope I just suggested to you you may
merely be a mislabel now its prediction
the acid test of diagnosis often in our
papers we like to say well if I'm able
to predict this that must mean that and
predicted reproducibly in multiple
populations
perhaps I'm looking at something causal
and I would and that it relates in some
fundamental way to diagnosis I'd like to
suggest that that's probably not the
case so just stare at the screen for a
little bit and focus on the fact that
this is a screen that was done by
Griffin Webber looking at survival three
years after test Beth this is
specifically on white blood cell count
but Griffin has done this as you'll see
on hundreds of other tests and what
shows you is your chance of dying if
you're like me between 50 and 69 years
old and you have a low white blood count
between 12 a.m. and 8:00 a.m. your
chance of dying is greater than 50% in
the next three years whereas if it's
obtained between 8:00 a.m. and 4:00 p.m.
the chance of dying is less than 3% so
why would that be no it's not circadian
rhythm it's because if your blood is
drawn at 3 o'clock in the morning it
means that the doctor is extremely
worried about you drawing doctors
contrary to some opinions is are not
status and they will not choose to draw
blood 3 o'clock in the morning unless
they extremely worried about you
and so rather than treating that
variance as noise as some data
scientists will and this is part of the
problem of not treating clinical data
from a knowledge-based perspective
understanding how the data was actually
obtained if you didn't know that you
treat all these all that variants that
you see on this screen as noise but in
fact it's a very very informative signal
and it's biased so if you treat as noise
you'll run aground in some wrong
conclusions whereas if you understand
that there's on the one type patient
pathophysiology
but also superimpose what we call
healthcare system dynamics which is the
behavior of the healthcare system
including informed doctors trying to do
the right thing then only by combining
these two these two signals will you
actually have a good understanding of
how this relates to the patient and in
fact if you see on this graph on the
x-axis is the odds ratio of death on the
y-axis is how much of the signal is
relative to the lab test itself
you can see that there are many many lab
tests many many lab tests where merely
having the knowing that test was
obtained gives you a prediction of
higher mortality of course when you
combine it combined the lab value with
the health system dynamics the fact that
it was drawn at these times then you
have it even better signal next I'm
going to go on to how can clinical data
be used to clarify diagnostic boundaries
this is work done by finale doe she was
a postdoc with me and had finished at
MIT with a PhD in computer science and
now as a Harvard School of Engineering
and Applied Sciences has a assistant
professor of computer science and when I
approached her about the fact that I was
actually bothered by the fact that some
pediatricians when they were told by the
mothers that these kids with autism that
their children the mothers would say had
these bowel problems and they were they
were told by the pediatrician brain bad
tummy hurts and that's not my words
that's a verbatim quote and so now I did
was a very nice data-driven approach
using the clinical data obtained from
many of chronic health records using the
distributive query system called shrine
that goes over many i2b2 systems but I
don't have distracted with how we got
the data suffice it to say we had data
on thousands of individuals with autism
and what finale did is created a bit
vector for each of these patients
chunked into a 1:1 vector of each
six-month block all the way to 15 years
and each bit in the bit vector describes
whether that child would have one of
5,000 different diagnoses in that
six-month block so you can pick up each
block on the block as having five
thousand bits on and on.for
for 15 years
and so when she did that and applied a
unsupervised clustering algorithm to
these patient longitude data obtained
from the electronic health record when
she found it quite interesting what she
found was one group with a lot of
epilepsy greater than 8% epilepsy as
opposed to the background rate of 20%
epilepsy involved ISM in generality she
found another subgroup with a lot of
infections like pedis media and
[Music]
sinusitis and although it's not shown
here it was statistically significant
but not prevalent enough to make it onto
the graph a number of autoimmune
diseases such as inflammatory bowel
disease Crohn's ulcerative colitis and
type 1 diabetes and then there was a
third subgroup with ADHD so ADHD anxiety
and not shown here but for similar
reasons it was not frequent enough but
it was significant schizophrenia and
major depressive depression so what you
have here are three very distinct
biologies three very distinct clinical
courses of three populations that if you
just label them as autism and did a case
control with them
you would be mixing different biologies
as in the heart failure example I gave
you earlier on so that saying that
clinical data may in fact help us
separate these underlying diagnosis and
note that we use an unsupervised method
to define from a data-driven perspective
what might be the distinct subgroups
there and can we do similar things in
but using biology and genes so for
example with doctrine of zine who at a
time was a graduate student in Bonnie
burgers group at MIT we did a study
looking at gene expression in one of the
pathways that
with uncovered in that earlier autism
expression study that I told you about
namely the innate immune pathway and so
we took the CAG innate and union pathway
and we set across a whole bunch of
diseases that have that are shown on the
right
Republicans and genome biology to what
extent are these genes dysregulated in
these different diseases as it you can
see here there's quite a lot of overlap
but a way to perhaps quantify it better
is to just ask how does this type of
gene expression just in that pathway
classify all those different diseases
and although it's not at the level of
clinical actionability what you do see
here is that all of those diseases can
be classified someone effectively with
Arizona curb specifically different from
random and some of them quite a bit so
just based on that innate immune pathway
so that tells us there's a lot of
biological overlap between these
different diseases and that's important
not only for classification but thinking
about not only the mechanism disease but
I can treat it and press repurpose drugs
that are used to treat one disease to
another disease and really ask the
question for example in the psychiatric
diseases psychiatrists are very fast to
acknowledge that there is very
significant overlap in the
symptomatology of these different
diseases and because as I hope convinced
you there is a lot of financial
incentives to have different diagnosis
as well as a lot of personal incentives
to have different diagnosis you can
better appreciate how some of these
psychiatric diseases such as autism or
developmental diseases such as autism
when there was a reclassification of the
reclassification of autism in the dsm-5
manual there was a enormous furor
nationwide and on the one hand I want to
smile because I often tease Marc Newson
about how arcane some of his work on
ontology czar in this case the ontology
of the dsm-5 was making the front page
of many newspapers because it was so
important how patients were being piled
into that different diagnosis but note
that what happens when you pile
individuals into this categorical
diagnosis it causes different financial
and social effects to be met and the
claim that I hope I'm beginning to
bolster is that from a data-driven
perspective we can do a far more
transparent and robust job of defining
what actually constitutes these diseases
so as I've argued just now there's
implications for study and for treatment
you might want to study not all autism's
compared to let's say a neurotypical
individuals but pick a subgroup that are
much more biologically similar to one
another just as you would for heart
failure and if you went to a genetics
first approach it would not be apparent
that these diseases that there are these
subsets that the signal is just not
strong enough from a genetics first or
genetics only approach and clinicians
might miss it because even if you had a
huge practice of autism you might easily
miss the fact that there was this over a
participation of that inflammatory bowel
disease because even if he has a
lifetime practice of a thousand children
autism which by the ways I might be a
phenomenally large practice you probably
wouldn't expect to have more than ten
individuals with inflammatory bowel
disease so over a lifetime you might
just ascribe that to random bad luck
and then I sort of emphasize again the
unsupervised nature of the example I
gave you about clustering the electronic
health records versus the self-referent
self-referential and circular circular
supervised labeling because if we start
with a definitional categorical
diagnosis we're going to be stuck with
all the consequences of that which by
the way if we use artificial
intelligence techniques as we're getting
to do such as deep learning against
images but we're using as the gold
standard our categorical diagnosis we're
in some sense going to be limiting the
efficacy with this big data of our
diagnostic support because these big
data
Alvis algorithms will be limited to the
supposed gold standard definitions
through this supervised learning and so
again what I'm trying to argue for is
let's look at longitudinal large
datasets on populations to drive much in
a much more objective way what
constitutes our diagnosis and I also
want to argue too for a multi-modal
first exploration that is not
necessarily just going in a type first
or genetics first but as many people on
this phone call have in fact in their
own work Illustrated going at both in
that case both modalities but if there
are more than two in multiple mobile to
the same time and in our modern machine
learning frameworks there are no
theoretical reasons at least why we
should not do that
what about when there is no diagnosis
how can we use clinical data and big
data perhaps to to get there so this is
where I'm very proud actually to
describe my involvement in something
called the undiagnosed disease Network
which is a option from the very
successful undiagnosed disease
program at NIH and where we said and I'm
a PI on the coordinating Center where we
conceived of this network as being has
hosted where all the data all the
genomic data would be stored in the
cloud for all the clinical data would be
stored in the cloud and those of you who
are involved with human studies subjects
trials will recognize that it was a
major achievement for us to get all
seven academic health centers including
the NIH to agree to a single protocol
that a said that they would go with this
shared data resource that everybody
within the network would be able to see
the data and furthermore a patient could
be referred in to this network and then
go wherever they needed to be referred
to within this network so going from one
hospital to a complete different
hospital system something that does not
happen usually so by doing this by
taking these patients who have had
already prior to their application to
this network a Hegira
through multiple healthcare systems
trying to get a diagnosis we were able
to therefore obtain genome whole genome
sequencing or exome sequencing
phenotypic evaluation and coding per the
hpo terminology and referring these
patients to the right academic health
centers where the right individual can
evaluate them should point out in this
network we also have so we have two
sequencing centers we also have a
biological validation because you can
appreciate that many mutations that look
like they were going to loss of function
often don't have a great loss of
function so there's a Drosophila and
zebrafish core we're using CRISPR they
knock in the human mutation equivalent
into these organisms to see to cause the
phenotypes so we can better assess the
pathogenicity of these variants
and the point is based on the approach
that was pioneered at the UDP we're
finding that we're making a lot of
diagnosis and this is now out of date we
have received well over I think 1,100
applications and over 500 or 600 are
under review and actually over 500
participants have been accepted and I
think on the order of 80 new diagnoses
have been made so when there's no
diagnosis what we're doing now is if
there's a high probability causal
variant we're going to link and as we
have for I think on the order of 80
patients this new diagnostic label
linking the clinical findings in that
patient to that variant but I think we
have to be vigilant because do all
individuals with that variant have
disease I think the the programs that
we've identified do have a causal link
from that parent to that disease but how
does genetic background in other
individuals different genetic
backgrounds and different environmental
exposures have a phenotype that's
affected by that variant and another way
I can say it is we know intuitively and
mathematically the probability of
disease given variant is not the same
thing as a probability of American
disease but in practice we don't behave
as if we know this and for a long time
there was a number of bearings in the
HFE gene which were considered to be
pathogenic for human chromic OSIS and
indeed if you look at hereditary
haemochromatosis clinics 80 percent of
individuals in those clinics will have
one of a small number of variants in
each HFE of mutations in the HFE gene
but then a study was done an amazing
study was done at Kaiser Permanente by
researchers from Scripps when a
genotyped I believe it
was over 44,000 individuals with
hemochromatosis and they found I think a
hundred and fifty one who are homozygous
or one of those no mutations and of
those hundred fifty one only one had any
clinical evidence or family history of
hemochromatosis
so the penetrance went from eighty
percent in the hereditary
haemochromatosis clinic to less than one
percent and that's because the
individuals in Kaiser has very different
very different genetic backgrounds and
very different exposures and in case
that doesn't convince you some other
papers which looked at three different
mouse strains with a chip with the HIV
mutation of those Mouse trains only one
of the three Mouse trains shown and
showed evidence of hemochromatosis so
the point is we are making these new
diagnoses in the undiagnosed disease
Network but we have to be careful not to
make the same error and the way to avoid
making that same error is going to be
the emergence of all these large-scale
population screening sorry Janine
genomic sequencing which will give us
what are the probabilities of those
variants in the general population so
that we can have a better sense of how
they are linked to health and disease
so in closing I'm going to ask the
following question why is medicine so
dependent on catechol categorical
diagnosis well there was a question that
was after the New England Journal of
Medicine 33 years ago they basically
asked I mean they literally asked if you
have a disease that's 1 in 1,000 and you
have this test that has a sensitive
sensitivity of 100% and have a
specificity of 95% so those are very
good-looking that's a very good-looking
test 100% sense of 95% 95% specific very
few genetic tests can even approach that
level of performance so in with it's one
in thousand disease if what's your
problem what's the problem
el-tee up half of having disease if your
test positive for in that test and a
bunch of Harvard doctors and students
were asked to study four years ago and
reported upon in the numeron Journal
about half the doctors answered greater
than ninety percent and half the doctors
answered around one to two percent and
just for those of you who are fallen
asleep I'll just remind you that right
answer is so if you two thousand
individuals one will be a true positive
because it's avoiding the thousand
disease and you'll have because it's 95
percent specific you'll have 550 false
positive so you'll have fifty-one
positives total only one of them are
true so that if you test positive on
that genetic test with those remarkable
characteristics none less your chance of
having the disease is less than two
percent
33 years 33 years later we ran the same
test on on Harvard doctors and students
and we essentially found exactly the
same distribution but the customer using
the same same question we've been
publishing in general but in JAMA
internal medicine and so my point is
this human beings are not good
probabilistic machines we don't have
we're not in a bayesian it based on
machines intuitively and therefore
having a categorical diagnosis is really
cognitively necessary for us but that
creates a real problem when we're
entering this age of millions of genetic
tests how are we going to navigate the
fact that we're not natural Bayesian
machines so I will now summarize so that
I can get to any questions our addiction
to chemical categorical diagnosis is
cognitively useful and will likely
continue for that reason but Cara
categorical diagnosis can result in
spurious biological and clinical
inference that it's often manipulated
for dollars or for a non-pecuniary
secondary agenda I want to point out
remind us that the prediction of
dynamics diagnostic class does not
necessarily provide evidence of
biological etiology and I hope I've
begun to convince you at least
diagnoses are more robust when they're
data-driven when you formally model
health system dynamics for clinically
acquired data that is specifically
informed that in the spirit of the
precision medicine report when it's
multimodal when you're looking at more
than one data type at a time you're
actually going to do better and to avoid
circularity of this diagnostic category
called problem having it unsupervised
rather than or lightly supervised
approach rather than the fully
supervised approach may be advisable and
because the first point because of the
cognitive utility of categorical
diagnosis I think we have very little
choice at this point other than to
recognize the necessity of having
computational decision support that will
actually substitute for our non-bayesian
wetware with a computational software
and hardware that does in fact do the
appropriate probabilistic assessment of
post-test probability of various disease
combinations and with that I want to
thank you for your patience and thank my
collaborators for their work and I'll
stop here and I'll see if there are any
questions and I leave it to mark to be
master of ceremonies thank you that was
a great talk I really appreciate that as
to all the people listening on the
webinar as you know there is a box where
you can type in your questions and what
I will do is try to synthesize and
restate the question so we can have a
little bit of order as we ask Zack to
expand and some of the issues that he's
raised today so please think about your
questions put them into the question box
and while you're doing that let me let
me ask you've raised lots of issues
about the messiness with which we
categorize disease with the messiness
with which we record data basically with
all the complexities of clinical
information and I'm just wondering what
are the implications of all that for
like electronic health records if we can
start from scratch how would you design
in the age
to accommodate all of this well first of
all I want to paint the positive version
of that so the same the same argument
can be made about claims data so claims
data are comprehensive so they don't
have s skin bias but there certain bias
for financial gain and there's so many
more coarse-grained than many of th RS
but a smart and meticulous individuals
have been able to use the claims data to
answer real questions by combining in
various creative probabilistic fashion
different claims codes to identify the
right patient populations similarly I
will say that you can use perhaps using
some of methods I refer to but not
necessarily you can actually go against
the existing medical messy data codified
data in the variety of ways to obtain
some probabilistic estimates of what the
underlying
true patient clusters are but to answer
your question directly
if I were perhaps at Google which I'm
not I might argue that dear oncologist
we wipe the floor with you regularly
just by doing brute force a machine
learning system machine learning over
the textual corpora and we actually
never fully not until the very end do we
do any labeling of ontology
but we actually calculate piece of
similarity across for example all the
word vectors across all these patients
and so I would say that I would not
redesign the EHRs from scratch because
we've already spent several billion
dollars and but I would perhaps in
addition to be optimistic on how we can
use with the codified data I think there
is a much more modern physical framework
so you look at the clinical notes that
will be quite helpful ironically
actually some of the cut-and-paste
facilities and EHRs will actually take
away
from some of the signal in these
clinical notes because of course people
like cutting and pasting
but of course takes away a lot of signal
from the richness that normally is in
human text Thanks what lowered going
through questions if you get others
requests to put up your conclusions
flight again so people can take a look
at those bullet points already you can
just back up your slide and question
from an ontology lover what is your
advice to librarians working with EMR
biobank redcap groups etc given our
tendency to categorize how can we help
our patrons think and plan for our new
paradigm we work with researchers
physicians who contribute to the
classification or reclassification
efforts of diseases what would you tell
these people so I'll tell me two things
first of all a very tactical thing to do
is to say why don't you have your ear
researchers at least analyze in two ways
the way they originally did it but then
use some use a set of categorizations
that lump together similar things
relatively robustly like feed wasps
codes so few s codes were developed at
Vanderbilt in order for them to be able
to look at different diseases because of
course icd-9 does not do a great job of
maintaining that kind of hierarchy but
even fee wasps itself is insufficient
but I would say that if we use that or
whatever ontology mark you with because
you're far more experienced than I am
would point to but I found that vos
codes by the way are actually quite
useful in rolling it up you can see
whether it's it's a robust finding
robust Association robust cluster rather
than just a artifact of the ontology the
harder way to do it but the one that's I
think much more consonant with our bd2k
spirit is to actually use the primary
data itself and say for
cluster the data by the primary primary
data press principal component analysis
or some other dimensional analogy
reduction technique to see if these
patients that we've labeled certainly in
a certain way in fact clustered together
because that will give you a good smell
test whether the categorization that
you're using is in fact robust relative
the question you're asking
there's an interesting corollary
question that comes from Jim Cimino what
are the implications for race as a
demographic I think that's it's this is
a very very tough one because I think I
showed you how not doing this in one way
created a lot of problems and so we're
we're stuck with a phone on the good
news used to be that self-identified
race correlates well with what the EHR
thinks your race is in other words in
those administrators are subtracting
patients someone the problem is that's a
quirk as well as we've come in
increasingly multiracial society and so
I think that what we're going to have to
start doing is using different
modalities depending on what the purpose
is so if you really want to find
continent of origin probably looking at
a few hundred snips and that's all it
takes these days just a few hundred
snips have been identified that fairly
reliable continent or of origin and
we'll give you the mixture of content
origin those who use those of you who've
used 23andme
can see that and I think that's the
answer by the way of how we will have to
categorize patients and so if you want
to do a case control study I think as
has been done in population genetics now
for a long time but not in clinical
medicine
we'll have to compare in populations on
those
on those genetic backgrounds as
determined by the snakes but that only
satisfies a certain class of questions
there are other classic questions that
are still going to be much more informed
by what your identification is and
that's a much more complicated story and
I'm sure we could have and wrap should
have a much longer discussion about it
another question here wants to know what
are the implications for gender and sex
given that we're moving into an era
where gender and sexual not viewed as
binary classifications well speaking as
a pediatric endocrinologist I think
that's a very good question and
certainly just having the male and
female genders on the electronic health
record for the most part is not very
helpful in supporting that mechanism now
I know that the diagnosis that the EHRs
have changed recently to support that a
multiplicity of gender assignments but
or gen assignments but it's not clear
how they're being informed with a
patient's by the clinician and so if we
want to use these for studies I think
somebody's going to have to come
together and decide how we're going to
represent it in a way that reflects both
and maybe simultaneously biological
measurements and patient identity
because we recognize that there is in
gender in these identity there is zero
what your sexual organs look like or
your chromosomal arrangement looks like
where your mutations are affecting or
not different hormones that are
associated with different traditional
gender identities and so again I think
that part is a purely biological part of
this that I
we can and should capture in EHRs but
then there's also the self
identification part which I know is
complicated but I think also does inform
us about some aspects of the patient
that we have to also figure out how to
capture the EHR and I'm not clear that
we've done that yet you know I agree
that we've reached the end of the hour
and I want to thank you for a really
illuminating talk if you look at the
questions that is still posted you'll
see a number of listeners have basically
just posted a thank you because this is
such a stimulating conversation really
want to thank you for your contribution
and thank everyone who dives in today
thank you very much for your attention